So now that we know the inputs and the outputs,
the procedure almost writes itself. Especially since we already know the
code that we wanted to execute before we defined the procedure.
So I'm going to write the procedure, by modifying the code here.
So first what we're going to do is make a little space.
Erasing the code that's not part of the 4 lines that we
want to turn in the procedure. So now I've, I haven't
modified the code at all. What I have is, almost exactly what
I need for the body of the procedure. This is what
we want to do. What we need to do is modify that to
get in the inputs, and turn it into a procedure. So, to
make it a procedure, we need to use the def name syntax.
So we're going to define the procedure. Get next target. So
now we need our parameters, the parameters are the inputs for
the procedures and we decided what the input should be.
Is the web contents that's the string giving the contents to
the webpage and that's what we had in the variable
page. So we can call that page again here, that's what
we are passing in as our input and now we have
the body of the procedure. The code is exactly the same
as the code we had before. But this time, instead of page
being whatever it was here, page is whatever we pass in as
the input to the procedure. And we can change the name of
the page. It sort of makes sense to change that name. This
code works no matter what we pass in. It doesn't have to
be a webpage. Any string that we pass in, this code will
find it. So it makes more sense to give it a slightly
more generic name. We'll change the name to S. If we change
the name of the parameter, well everywhere that we use page,
now we don't have the value of page. What we have
is the value of S, which is the name of the
parameter. So we'll change all of those to S's as well. So
we're almost done. There is one big thing we have left
to do and that's how do we get the outputs. Right
we said what we wanted the outputs to be is the
URL and the value of end-quote. We need some way of getting
those back and the way that you do that
is to use return. Return's a special construct in
python. So we have the keyword return, followed by
a list of all the things that we want
to return from the procedure. So what we return
is a list of any number of expressions, seperated
by commas. We can have zero return expressions, that
would mean there's no output. And it actually is useful
to have procedures with no output sometimes. That's not true if
we just think of procedures as things that map inputs to
outputs, but procedures can also do other things. They can do
what we call side-effects, and what side-effects are, are things that we
can see, but that aren't the outputs. And an example of
a side-effect would be, well, if we printed something out, we would
see that result happen. We'd see everything that happens when the
code and procedure runs. But we wouldn't get it as an output.
So, in this case, we do want to have outputs from get
next target. We want to return results, so we know how to
continue. And we decided what the output should be, are the
value of the URL. So we want to find the string that's the
next target. And the value of the end quote, so we
know the position where it was found. So let's see if you
can figure out how to finish the return statement. And your
goal is to figure out the code that we need after the
return, to finish this procedure.